no se ha emitido una primera reacción
tras recibir la respuesta por escrito de
los norteamericanos a su petición de
garantías de seguridad
recordemos que era sobre todo que
ucrania no entre jamás en la otan que no
haya más ampliaciones de la otan hacia
el este que se retiren los misiles que
están más cerca de las fronteras de
rusia eeuu adelantó ayer que estaba
dispuesto a hablar pero que no había
incluido en esa contestación su
disposición a cerrar las puertas de la
otan a ucrania hoy moscú ha dicho que
cree que todavía hay espacio y tiempo
para seguir dialogando aunque el
portavoz del kremlin dmitri peskov sí
que ha adelantado que siguen hablando
pero con poco optimismo porque según los
rusos los norteamericanos no están
entendiendo y no han satisfecho la parte
más importante de esa petición de
garantías de seguridad en todo caso la
noticia que se va a seguir hablando ha
sido recibida aquí
con algo de alivio